it's thought to be the world's most
powerful volcanic eruption in 30 years
the explosion of the hungar tonga hunga
ha upai volcano on saturday caused a
sonic boom that could be heard six
thousand miles away in alaska and
cloaked part of the pacific in ash
this afternoon the brother of missing
british woman angela glover confirmed
she'd been found dead it's reported she
was swept away by this tsunami wave that
hit the coast of tonga 20 minutes after
the eruption
she's beautiful she was absolutely a ray
of sunshine um that
she would walk into a room and just
lighten the room up and she
loved her life both when she was working
in london and then she achieved her life
stream of going to work in the south
pacific
the tsunami is expected to have caused
extensive damage to low-lying parts of
tonga but details are scarce the
submarine cable that connects the
islands to the rest of the world has
been damaged
the cloud of volcanic ash is blocking
satellite communications
we'd be able to make contact with our
teams on the ground through things like
satellite phone technology but because
of the ash cloud even that kind of
communication has been severely impacted
we have not had uh con
contact with our red cross team on the
ground since saturday afternoon just
after the eruption itself
it's difficult to imagine the impact on
tonga given the tsunami caused damage
along the coast of south america
two people reportedly drowned off a
beach in peru in unexpectedly high waves
and the eruption more like a detonation
sent shockwaves literally around the
world
these satellite images show the pressure
wave moving at the speed of sound away
from the pacific
the eruption was so powerful those shock
waves were being detected on pressure
gauges at weather stations like this one
around the world in fact faint ripples
are still passing through the atmosphere
more than two days after the event
so we saw the first wave and then we
probably saw the second wave as it
reflected back and during the course of
today we've probably seen another couple
of waves as it's gone back and forth
just like ripples in the swimming pool
i've been looking at pressure records
for nine fifty years and i've never seen
anything as strong as this
instruments around the world witnessed
the eruption in real time but until
reconnaissance flights from new zealand
and australia return the outside world
has little idea how much tonga has
suffered and how much help it will need
tom clark sky news